[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département 800 c'est le
nombre d'élèves réunis aujourd'hui
autour de la même passion celle du sport
c'est à l'étang salé que s'est tenu le
premier challenge sportif départemental
des collèges ces jeunes se sont mesurés
sur une dizaine d'épreuves
une action soutenue par le département
au travers de l'union nationale du sport
scolaire et des associations sportives
de parent c'est vraiment affreux ville
la marraine cet été a qui sont là et
voilà je suis sûr et certain que parmi
tous ces jeunes là il y en aura un ou
deux même plaisir j'espère qu'il sera un
jour qu'il faudra fuir les flambeaux de
la réunion ces jeunes représentent
l'avenir l'avenir de la région l'avenir
de notre pays
ce sont des sur les citoyens c'est la
santé c'est adam confiance en soi ça
vous plaît mais aussi de bien réussir
vos études
cyrille melchior et patrick lebreton
maire de la commune de saint-joseph sint
ensemble le pacte de solidarité
territoriale le département accompagne
le développement de la commune avec une
enveloppe de 3,2 millions d'euros en
investissement et de 600000 euros en
fonctionnement
c'est faire du social dans l'enfer des
personnes en difficulté c'est aussi
participer à l'aménagement du territoire
quand on aménage le territoire on met en
place des équipements qui rendent
service aussi bien aux jeunes comme aux
moins jeunes mais aussi aux dates de
l'activité dans un département qui
souffre d'un taux de chômage élevé
mais l'on soutient aussi l'activité
économique l'activité des entreprises et
d'une belle entreprise communal c'est
original à san jose
puis à toulouse et connaît un gros mal
c'est la solitude mais c'est contre ça
qu'il faut se battre et nous on est dans
une démarche aujourd'hui d'amener de
l'animation à domicile qu'il a su on a
rencontré donc un acteur qui veut nous
aider parce que c'est sa mission
principale sa compétence à savoir le
conseil départemental avec le président
sur imac colère le département de la
réunion a reçu tous les principaux les
gestionnaires des collèges publics et
privés de lille
l'occasion pour l'équipe éducative de
rappeler les grands axes de soutien et
de développement portés par la
collectivité via le projet de
construction de reconstruction et les
projets de réhabilitation de rénovation
en tous les cas ce que je peux dire en
un mot c'est que le département heures
avec le comment la volonté de le
président cyrille melchior
c'est de faire en sorte qu'ils aient un
mieux vivre pour notre jeunesse
réunionnaise ou au milieu
en fait dans l'éducation même et nous y
apportons notre pierre et combien utile
pour beaucoup d'entre nous
le bonus de cette semaine c'est ces
images exceptionnelles du site de
langevin tournée pour cet épisode de la
réunion par les équipes du département
[Musique]
oh
o o
ouah
non
oh
ou répondre
il n'a jamais jamais connu
non
[Musique]